why do you think most people don't ever
reach Financial Freedom in their lives
this is where people get it so wrong one
of the secrets to success is
turning over millions a year after
spending 15 years on Wall Street he's
now sharing her secrets to the World on
how to make money I think that is the
question everyone's asking themselves I
think every human should understand the
language of money it's not that complex
we just make it sound complex because
the less people speak our language the
more we can charge them for the first
time in 25 years the richest one percent
will control more than half of the
world's wealth by next year the Gap is
huge this is why only one in 10 people
dies wealthy if you understand the
language you can become an expert and an
expertise leads to a bunch of cash what
have you come to learn about what holds
us back in that moment the people who
love you they want what's best for them
which is that you're safe you're secure
everything's okay my loved ones were
super supportive but they were always
saying things like is the grass Always
Greener Cody and so we've become a
generation of vitamin D deficient
alternative milk drinking softies
so I had a job I shouldn't have been at
the guy I shouldn't have been with in a
place I shouldn't live but I was too
scared I'm not one of those
entrepreneurs that just burn the bridges
or sleep on the couch and so I needed
something where I could stair step my
way out of a corporate job and then I
realized this could be way bigger than
what anybody else could pay me we zoom
in on that moment what would you
recommend my first step be Cody so first
you have to
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode Cody
[Music]
who are you speaking to and what is the
message that you're trying to send them
I think that every man and woman
maybe people like you and I when we were
younger before we had any zeros or
businesses
and the measures the message is very
simple it's that I think by and large
and maybe they could feel this inside
them too we've slowly gone from a nation
of owners or a country of owners or a
world of owners to a nation of renters
or surfs in another word
and the idea is what if we could take
that back
and that's the whole premise of
everything we do is getting people into
the owner's chair into ownership as
opposed to letting other people be the
architects of their lives and it took me
way too long to do that and so I'm
hoping that it will take other people
less time if we share give me the
Persona then if someone that you believe
will find Value in this conversation
like where are they are they in their
life what are they thinking day to day
um what are their aspirations yeah I
think there's sort of three humans that
I picture there's one that I call work
in John
and um and he is basically or she but I
just have a male Avatar for this one is
sitting at a job right now that they
don't really like doing things they
don't want to do for people they don't
like and building their dream and their
Castle
and they're mad about it although your
choice to be there but they're mad about
that decision and they wanna they want a
way out but they have either golden
handcuffs or they make too much money or
they have responsibility bills that have
to be paid and so they don't really feel
like they have a solution except going
to find like the next best but kind of
still worst company and then the second
avatar is there's an there's an aging
population that by and large in the
workforce we say you're over 50 or 60.
like you're not getting as many job
looks as you were before but now we live
until we're 90. so what are they
supposed to do for 30 40 years and I
think their evolution can be also buying
a business taking over something
becoming an owner and maybe something
not aggressive as aggressive as they
were before and then I think the the
third Avatar are humans
who kind of got sold pipe dreams over
the last couple years like if I buy 472
houses that pay me a hundred bucks a
month profit uh all finally become
financially free well it takes a lot of
cash to do that or you know if I have
nfts on the side or if I go into the
stock market on the side all of which
aren't rigged games exactly but are
meant to just beat inflation and so that
third group of people might like what
they're doing they just need they need
something else on the side it's a little
bit of a safety net because I don't
think our safety nets will be around by
the time we need them and you've been
through your own Journey from the
corporate world to working in finance
working as a journalist where you are
now which one of those avatars did you
represent well I was definitely a work
in John so that would have been the
first one when I was in finance I was
doing well but I definitely felt trapped
I mean I was all those things I was
should have been happy and content with
where I was but felt
like the 60 hour work weeks were too
much and I didn't really like the
culture of the company that I was
working for I had a lot of respect for
the CEO but I didn't really fit and uh
but I was too scared I'm like a little
bit of a scaredy cat I'm not one of
those entrepreneurs like our mutual
friend Alex who just was like burn the
bridges or sleep on the couch you know
I'll sell it all that's just not me it's
too scary and so I needed something
where I could have like a soft Landing I
could stair-step my way out of a
corporate job so I started buying these
small businesses with the idea that
maybe one day they could just meet meet
my costs and then I realized oh God I'm
thinking so small this could be way
bigger than what anybody else could pay
me but I was a work in John for sure
we zoom in on that moment because I
think most people listening to this now
can can relate to that moment of
maybe hearing you speak and hearing your
content online or hearing an Alex Emoji
or whatever hearing Gary vaynerchuk
whoever it might be
talk about starting that business
pursuing that side Hustle but there's
this psychological
barrier to overcome which most of us
can't overcome we call it fear we say
you know that I'm waiting for the
perfect time I don't have the confidence
if you zoom in on that now you've
started this new journey in your life
where you're creating content and you're
advising people on how they can pursue
the paths that you've pursued it
yourself what have you come to learn
about what holds us back in that moment
and the and the maybe the falseness of
the stories we tell ourselves you
described it as being a scaredy cat yeah
I
at least for myself what I'll say is you
know daughter of immigrants
um who thought that what I had achieved
was the Pinnacle you know people that I
love more than anybody in the world and
maybe that's similar for a lot of people
listening the people who love you they
want what's best for them typically
which is that you're safe you're secure
everything's okay they don't really want
what's quote unquote best for you
because that's actually the scary thing
real growth happens when you take huge
risks and you potentially fail and you
realize that you're not going to die and
so I realized that my loved ones were
some of the reasons that were actually
holding me back
um super supportive but they were always
saying things like is the grass Always
Greener Cody you know what about this
next thing is that really going to make
you happy you know are you sure it's not
you is it them and in some cases they're
right I just have that that ridiculous
urge to keep growing and doing more but
that that made me jump from one two
three four five five finance companies
in like 10 years or something like that
because I thought it was each it was the
individual company and I didn't realize
oh no I'm just like unemployable I want
to work for myself I'm not going to be
great at being at somebody else's
employee
um but it was the stories that I heard
again and again from my family because
they wanted to keep me safe very kind
but not right for me
so in your life there comes a moment
where you make this kind of peculiar
decision when I say peculiar because
most people don't make the decision to
um start off ramping from the corporate
world essentially yeah you you buy your
first business
right so you're you're in a job yep and
while you're in the job you decide to
buy a business yeah did you have loads
of cash when you did that no no no in
fact and why did you do it what was the
what was the thought process that made
you go do you know what that's a good
idea
usually triggered from from some sort of
pain like at that time
I was was fighting a little bit with the
CEO of the company that I was working in
and they really wanted me to they wanted
me to run this business that I'd taken
from zero to a couple billion in assets
under management and they wanted me to
continue running it but I started
getting press and stuff started
happening because we had had this growth
and they wanted me to do it really
quietly and
um not as much the CEO but some of the
other managing directors I was by far
the youngest I was the only female and
um you know
that company is wild but they basically
in many ways were like
um you need to do it our way and I was
like well your way didn't get you to
this couple billion dollars on a
management it works great for you guys
over here but it didn't over there so no
I'm gonna run the business this way and
uh and so we were kind of arguing a
little bit and I think I saw the writing
on the wall that it wasn't my Casino
they weren't my chips I was working for
somebody else and at the end of the day
they were writing the rules as is fair
it was their business and I knew that at
some point I was either going to get
pushed out or leave and so at that point
I started buying these businesses on the
side because I wasn't sure I wanted to
work for somebody ever again
I'm I'm fascinated by the first step
people take because the first step seems
to be the hardest that first step to
buying that first business and you're
stepping out into uncertainty and the
unknown there and that's really like
that
you know if I could give one thing to
the audiences that have listened to me
for the last 10 years on social media
and on this podcast it would just be the
answer to taking that first step like
out into like you did at 29 30 to buy
that first business talk me talk to me
about specifically that first one what
were you looking for yep what was your
thesis and
um
I guess how did you learn how did you
learn about buying as you call them
boring businesses yeah well I had a
benefit which is as a journalist I sort
of infiltrated Finance I'm not
technically as intelligent uh you know
I'm not as I'm not a financial modeling
Guru I'm not a lot of things that people
are in finance but I'm pretty decent at
asking questions and then figuring out
who are the right people that could get
me the answers and so what I realized
pretty quickly is we were doing a bunch
of deals you know I was doing deals that
were tens of millions hundreds of
millions and billion dollar deals and I
don't know why it took me so long but I
realized there's no difference like
materially between a billion dollar a
hundred million dollar a 10 million
dollar deal and a one million dollar
deal and if that's the case then I bet
if I have a couple hundred thousand or
ten thousand dollars I could do a much
smaller deal wouldn't I be able to do
the exact same thing so I saw behind the
curtain uh you know like at The Wizard
of Oz and realized that the wizard was
actually pretty short
and because I saw that then I just said
well now we just work backwards and just
like you would buy you know a hundred
million dollar
condo unit or you know Condo building
you could see how you could go all the
way back and buy your first studio right
it's the same thing with businesses it's
just stair stepping real estate and so I
at the time my biggest constraint was
not knowledge I knew how to do deals it
was time you know I was working 60 70
hours a week and so one of the first
deals I did was a laundromat deal
because I figured well you don't need
somebody to run it full time and it was
a 100K transaction and so that wouldn't
bankrupt me and you know I could buy a
little business like this and that
business could keep running even while I
wasn't there and I could have an
operator that could probably help me
with anything that went sideways where
did you find a laundromat to buy 400k or
was that website did you know the guy no
no the guy so basically what happened
for my first deals I didn't have a
framework so it was just hey I do these
really big deals could I do a smaller
deal and if I could do a smaller deal
what would be the easiest small deal to
do that would be the least risk and so
at the time I knew a guy that was
running a couple of laundromats so I
basically said to him hey if I find one
for you will you help me operate it and
he knew how to do that so the very first
one we had was in California and that's
one of the secrets to this is two things
first you have to learn how to do deals
which is not really that complex we just
make it sound complex in finance because
Financial lingo is like the moat around
how we make money right the less people
speak our language the more we can
charge them which is the secret and then
the second aspect was how to run a
laundromat right like I don't know
machine breaks what am I going to do and
so then I had this guy who knew how to
run these and I could just find the deal
for him close the deal for him and be
the cash for him why did they sell to
you
old you know these are 68 year old
owners of a business that have been
running this laundromat plus a bunch of
other small businesses in the vicinity
for 20 30 years and so can you imagine
running your podcast for 30 years would
probably be fun but by the end you might
be open to selling now imagine you had a
laundromat for 30 years you know you're
dealing with broken machines or there's
somebody who's homeless messing around
with some stuff at a certain point you
don't even want to continue with a
profitable business and this is where
people get it so wrong all the time on
the internet people love to tell me no
way would anybody sell a business that
business made sixty seven thousand
dollars in profit so I bought it for
100k a year
did 67 000 and people on the internet do
one or two things to that they go no
[__] way didn't happen and why would
somebody sell and like did you give them
a bad deal
and the second
uh group of people go that's a terrible
deal I'd never do that deal because you
don't have enough profit in that for
that to be a business not a job
so those are the two two things and the
first one I'd say in the US right now
there are tens of millions of small
businesses for sale that will never sell
and and I tell a story about my uncle
Leb who had a small business that was
exactly that
um that he closed down which by the way
costs you money as opposed to selling
because he had no idea his business was
sellable like many businesses that I had
before I did this I shut down instead of
selling them I didn't even realize that
even though I was in finance and then to
the second group I'd say you start with
a small business that probably isn't the
greatest business for you to own long
term but businesses are like real estate
you can turn around and sell them after
you get in the game but I think of these
businesses I call them gateway drug
businesses they're they're the once you
learn how to do a deal you'll you'll
never see the world the same again it
will change your entire perspective on
everything you will walk in everywhere
and you will realize that business is
full of masochists like you and me who
do this despite it being awful many
times but we love it in some way but at
some point we're going to want to sell
our thing and move on to the next and so
everywhere around you right now wherever
you are somebody sitting next to you
wants to sell their business and what if
you could figure out how to buy that
business put in an operator in it and
then do it again and again and again and
that's the only difference between you
and Warren Buffett or Blackstone are
these big huge companies is it important
to have competence in the area and the
industry that you're trying to buy these
small businesses in in your point of
view not really no not at all but it
helps right oh of course it helps
um more important than anything is it's
sort of like real estate it's really
about the deal can you understand can
you read a balance sheet can you
understand profit and loss which is not
that difficult to understand and then
can you figure out how to get to the
person that can get you answers so for
instance I didn't know anything about
laundromats but I knew a guy who knew
laundromats
um often what I tell people these days
is I'm a I'm more old school like I
would go knock on doors and I would
Shake business owners hands but uh you
could also go to Reddit where there are
uh platforms with a hundred thousand
electricians on them and so if you
wanted to buy an HVAC company which was
which is like heating uh air
conditioning and often electric
electricity I would go on there and I
would try to find electricians in my
local area and I would ask them
questions and I would pay them for an
hour consult to figure out how to run
this business I think we forget in this
day and age how easy it is to get the
information that we want and so we
listen to the fear of the fact that we
don't know what we're doing and I
actually that's irrational I think it's
really easy for somebody to tell you why
things won't work it's actually quite
hard to convince somebody that they're
capable of doing something
what if I don't have 100K you had 100K
right yeah say I'm working a job I've
saved up only five thousand dollars yeah
well I've bought a business for three
thousand dollars I've bought a business
for eight thousand dollars and I've
bought many many businesses for zero
dollars and and I'm not saying this in a
way that's clickbaity will you go out
right now talk to somebody tomorrow and
be able to buy a business for zero
dollars like you're gonna need to do a
little work
um just on the structuring of the deal
right just on the structuring of the
deal so they get paid on performance
exactly or they get paid on what's
called seller financing so these you
know you can go and most businesses most
small businesses below 10 million
dollars in Revenue
sixty percent of them sell with some
component of seller financing which just
means if let's say you know somebody
manages your property here let's say
that that property manager makes 100K a
year profit they want to sell their
business you're a terrible tenant they
can't handle it anymore
and they sell that business they want to
sell that business typically for two to
five x profit that's what these small
businesses go for and the the typically
there aren't enough buyers like there's
not a bunch of people running around
trying to buy property management
companies so what do they do instead
well you would come to them and say all
right I'll buy out your property
management company but
you're going to be my loan I'm going to
pay you a percent interest rate plus I'm
going to defer your tax burden so you
pay less than taxes nobody likes that
and uh and I'm going to buy the business
by giving you 300 000 with uh you know
over five years right so I'm going to
keep a percentage of the profits and I'm
going to give the rest to you and it's
not really that complex it's really what
happened to real estate before we had
Zillow and Redfin and all of these sites
that made it super normalized to sell
real estate
the as you said a second ago the real
key here is knowing the art of the
possible as it relates to Deals the way
you construct your deals so that
um you win yeah 100 basically well and
the I think the truth of deal making
that people forget about is that it is
one of the very few things where it's
never a zero Sun game yeah so if I go to
sell a stock I hope that when I sold the
stock I sold at the right time and you
bought at the wrong time right like
that's what we hope and buying and
selling small businesses that doesn't
have to be the case you know I could buy
I could sell my property management
company to you you could pay me 3x
profits and I could say but if the
company increases Revenue by x amount
which I think it will with these tweaks
and I kind of help you a little bit how
about you pay me 400 000 instead of
three hundred thousand and you would go
great if you hit those metrics no
problem that'd be an awesome deal for me
so there's plenty of ways to make sure
it's a win-win but to your point this is
why people are poor because nobody
teaches us the language of deals and if
somebody taught us not how to negotiate
our salary that's fine but how to
negotiate for equity and ownership the
world will look a whole lot different
but that's not in
the big pictures incentive it's really
good for the little guy not so good for
the big guy
the other thing when you're approaching
a business and trying to get them to
knowing this how to structure deal is
one thing but then there's an element of
persuasion and sales womanship yeah
involved in this
how important is is learning to sell and
how how can we be better sales people in
your view what is the key to being a
great salesperson because you must be to
be buying businesses you must be able to
figure out what someone wants and
present it to them
I truly believe that sales is a fallacy
I don't think sales exists I think you
find people who are already predisposed
to want what you are quote unquote
selling and I learned that very early on
from one of my mentors actually at
Goldman that you don't sell anybody on
anything you're never going to change
somebody's mind and if you think I'm
wrong go try to convince a republican to
become a Democrat right or a Tory to
become I don't know what's the other
side
okay and it doesn't really go very well
usually and so my belief is actually
what you're looking for is just who are
the people who are you're finding
trigger moments like if I was to have a
conversation with Stephen about selling
your business I would try I would be
asking questions like you know how's it
going running wow 20 years that's a long
time if their answer is [__] love
this business I am never selling this is
amazing you're like cool awesome no
problem so lovely meeting you but if you
meet the person that's like
yeah I'm ready I'm ready to retire I've
got this vision of a ranch in my head
out in the countryside and you know but
my kid doesn't want to take over the
business you're not you're not gonna get
them to think something different you're
purely discovering what they truly feel
and then you are going to be the person
that enables them to have a retirement
in a way that no government can like you
are the retirement plan and so that's
maybe what you need to learn is just
curiosity for another human and then you
need to understand what a what a
motivated seller looks like at a
motivated seller looks like somebody
who's ready for their next adventure
whatever that may be and if you can find
those two things then you find the
people that actually yes they want what
you're selling now what you actually do
have to convince somebody of and I hope
you're true about it is that you are
going to be a good shepherd if you are
going to be their retirement plan you
better not go broke right you better
actually be able to take this business
and run with it and so that is one part
where you have to convince like why
should I sell this business to you
Stephen how are you going to take care
of my business and that part really
again comes down to curiosity making
sure that you're setting yourself up and
the seller for Success not rocket
science
if I I'm gonna play um
I'm gonna play the role of a 25 year old
okay I'm working in a job I'm I've got a
little bit of disposal income but not a
ton yeah I'm listening to you Cody and
I'm going I want some of that you've got
a holding company right yeah you've got
a fund as well yeah how much roughly the
revenue of the holding company 70
million 70 million so your holding
company does about 70 million Revenue
you've got a fund as well yep how big is
the fund small 10. okay so 80 million
combined
um I want to get to where you're you are
but I'm currently working in a job I'm
25 years old I've got I know seven
thousand dollars in the bank seven
thousand Pounds in the bank whatever
what would you recommend my first step
be Cody how do I get out of this job
yeah well the first step if you if
you're gonna do it like a pro I'd say
this which is tell me what you do for a
living I do
content perfect
so if you do content for a living what
I'd say is don't buy a laundromat I talk
about laundromats I actually need to
change that I need to like tell somebody
I bought a different first business
because it's a terrible business to buy
it just was my first one and it's very
easy to understand so I'm like if you
can't understand quarter machine close
clean don't buy a business any business
just forget you heard me talk about
anything and so that's why I talk about
laundromats but if I was going to do it
the pro-way I would say you should use
your unfair advantage and if you're in
the content business don't buy a boring
business in the traditional sense look
around you I it's something I call my
personal p l review so I would basically
look at
what do I spend money on already if
you're in content you probably spend
money on ad purchasing right you
probably spend money on video production
you probably spend money on maybe you
rent a a set space do you have all these
expenses around you and what if you
could turn one or two of those expenses
into an asset not a liability thing that
makes you money not a thing that costs
you money and so you know I did a deal
back when I was doing more video
production in my last company where I
bought a podcast and video production
company and I did that deal basically
for zero dollars I think I put ten
thousand dollars down for that deal that
ended up doing about 300 400 000 a year
because I just said I know like five or
six other people that could use your
service I'm gonna like double your
Revenue by introducing you to these
people and I pay you let's say three
thousand dollars a month now what if
we're just gonna wipe that out if I can
hire these other people and you're gonna
give me 25 of the company or whatever
percentage it was that's what I would do
if I was you so if you're young and
hungry look around you and see what you
pay for and what you currently utilize
already and then try to get a percentage
of that business if not buying the whole
thing and that's sort of the pro way to
do it as opposed to Car Wash need to go
learn totally different Market you can
do the second it's just a little bit
riskier
so I'm I'm working in content 25 years
old seven thousand dollars in the bank
um I realize what you've just said and I
go you know I'm a marketing agency we
book a lot of Studios
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
approach a studio space
try and do a deal with them
and then I'm going to send clients their
way yeah you could totally do that
that'd be a Sweat Equity deal or a REV
Equity deal Revenue Equity deal so for a
studio space I mean I think the the
probably Pro way to do that would be one
you'd approach them and you'd kind of
get an understanding for their business
you'd be like how much revenue do you
make like how big is this you'd figure
out if you were material to their
business so me doing 3K a year with my
video production guy I was material to
his business he was only doing I don't
know you know a hundred thousand dollars
a year or something like that
and so if my 3K went away that was you
know that's like 20 of his business
right there over a yearly basis so if
you go to a studio production company
and they're like yeah we're doing seven
million dollars a year and you're paying
them 3K you're like all right cool
anyway nice to chat with you or you
could say you know who's the owner how
long you've been doing this and you
could dive into it and the other side of
the coin is you might find out that the
owner is 70 and you become buds with the
owner and the owner loves when you come
in because you're kind of like young and
you learn about what he does and then
you ask who's going to take over the
business and then you might say Hey you
know I do this other thing but I would
love to sort of be an apprentice to you
in a way and potentially buy your
business using future profits and you
can sort of like stay on and we can
stair step our way into this but would
you be open to that like leaving your
legacy to somebody like me and so you
could do it that way too
but I think it is learn it goes back to
kind of the smart question you asked
which is like the two avatars are who's
listening to this right now and then
that's the same question to the people
listening that you're going to ask the
owner what sort of Avatar is the owner
and how can you become the solution to
what that Avatar is looking for how can
you become the son to the father you
know how can you become the buyer to a
really anxious seller
um
and then you can get your deal done
why do you think most people
don't ever reach Financial Freedom in
their lives do you think it's a
psychology thing a mindset thing
obviously let's take you know the very
practical elements out of the equation
so you know severe hardship poverty all
of those kinds of things yeah but people
that are in that sort of middle layer
that are comfortable why do why do they
never some of those people never really
reach a point of Financial Freedom
I think
humans
defer to the paths they've seen before
them I think so often we follow in our
fathers or our mothers footsteps
and that's why I think the internet's
really powerful is you have an
opportunity to now choose the family
footsteps you want to follow into so one
I used to think it was just a knowledge
Gap
but then I I went to this event and I
was talking to my friend about it and
she uh said that the facilitator said
something really cool it was a group of
women imagine like 40 women a room right
and they're there to talk about finances
and in this room they said okay
everybody close your eyes
and I want you to picture money picture
money right now and then I want you to
turn your body into the shape you feel
when you hear the word money right and
so 30 women all eyes closed they take
whatever shape she goes now open your
eyes and look around and you know my
friend was explaining to me how most
people in the room are like fetal
position they were like holding they
were like really close somewhere on the
ground you know some were covering their
eyes so in a room of 30 relatively
successful women their reaction was like
attack shame guilt for money and she was
like you know she was standing there
with her arms open wide like you know
give me the money and when I think about
my relationship with money it's the same
thing I'm like if I think about money
I'm like yeah it's over here like my
hands are up like I am here for it but
most people have this weird emotional
attachment to money and so I used to
think that people on the internet like
not I like Tony Robbins but like Tony
Robbins or whatever who do a lot of the
motivational stuff I kind of didn't get
it I'm like just give me the tactics
skip the skip the other thing
and then I realized that most people
have really bad stories that they tell
themselves about money and you could
tell I mean it'd be interesting your
next speech you could try it I tried it
one of mine same thing men and women
holding each other like they're being
beaten when somebody talks about money
the average human feels that way
and so I think it all comes down to what
we believe which is hard for somebody in
finance like me to say you know
typically I would think well if you knew
what to do you could just do it but
that's not the case it's you have to
believe that you can do it and the only
way I can figure out to get more people
to believe that they can do it is to
show more people who are super normal or
in fact below average doing the damn
thing but if I had the answer to that
that'd be the million dollar question I
read a stat in the U.S that only one in
10 people dies wealthy in the U.S that
most people die broke and and young and
I thought that was fascinating because
we're at economic High Times Like lower
poverty levels than ever before but
still most people die
at least without extra cash to pass on
to the next generation
why do you think people don't reach
Financial Freedom or most people die
without a lot of cash I think um
obviously it's a very complex topic but
I think
I really resonate with the emotional
psychology psychological
side of things that you described you
know it's the same reason why most
people don't go to the gym or eat
healthy money is inherently emotional
when I was when I had no money I was
Reckless with money right all the
gambling shops are in the areas where
people don't have money
um
there's something deeply psychological
about money so I would if I when I was
working in those call centers if I got
paid a thousand pounds at the end of the
month I would the same day go and buy a
TV
or an Xbox like a PlayStation
for about six seven hundred pounds I
would not pay my rent to go and buy that
PlayStation and sometimes I'd buy the
PlayStation without having a TV there
was just something psychologically
attached to the I don't know the
dopamine rush or the sense of self-worth
that I got from owning the shiny thing
when I got money
my relationship with money
became amazing yeah I I stopped buying
designer things I stopped wasting it I
didn't feel a need to to show off or buy
you know Rolexes or whatever so I was
able to preserve wealth more there's a
really interesting relationship with
money on both ends of the spectrum when
you have less of it it's harder it's
often because of certain psychological
things in certain people I was one of
them it's harder to hold on to when you
have more of it it feels easier to hoard
and people you know
and more broadly on the on the subject
of um
why people don't reach Financial Freedom
I think
the modern world tells us that we can
get rich quick yeah and when you think
about how people build wealth we think
about the Warren buffetts of the world
it's so boring and slow and who's gonna
buy that book yeah you know get be a
billionaire at 87. I [__] what I'm not
going to be able to you know dance in
the Nightclub at 87 so why do I want a
billion then that's why the nft thing in
the crypto scam this whatever is also
appealing to people yeah because it's
quick yeah it's true well you know
what's I actually uh was reading
somewhere a story about in South Africa
in the slums they have the highest
concentration of the largest televisions
uh per square foot of the the house so
that you if you've been there and and
I've actually never been so I can't
validate but you will see very small
little rooms with huge televisions and
and I thought that was interesting
um but it actually makes sense because
maybe it comes down to a belief that
people don't think they're ever going to
get out and so they think the only
chance of getting out is going into
whatever the short-term pleasure is it's
like if you never think you're going to
escape your everyday reality which is
actually kind of miserable then you're
gonna buy the PlayStation because why
wouldn't you why would you save and try
to get out when you've never seen
anybody else get out but what is the
plate the PlayStation means so much more
to you in that moment than a PlayStation
it means it's your it's self-worth it's
one tiny token that you are
successful yeah that you can show your
friends or that you can just even fear
in self-esteem it's so much more than a
PlayStation
the thing that invalidates you in this
case money will be the thing that has
the greatest chance of making you feel
valid and so if in my house the lack of
money was always the thing that caused
my shame yeah so the minute I got any of
it I Would overcompensate by trying to
buy some [__] to show people yeah
um and then when I had loads of it who
gave a [__] like
yeah that's true that void was almost
filled so yeah it's true I also think
it's hard I mean I remember many times
where
uh you know I remember checking accounts
always being overdrawn and uh and you
know seeing the little negative pin on
my you know email and and cell phone
that you couldn't there was nothing else
in there you know when I was in college
and trying to figure it out before I
made any money I think I made like 37k
in my first job at a college
um so I definitely remember all that but
I think if you can have this belief and
you can get around other humans who have
have had success or are striving for
Success your aperture just opens in a
different way and then maybe the
commercials and the ads and the things
that make you feel like you want to buy
all the everyday stuff go away like I
don't really like I kind of viscerally
get mad when I see people who have
wealth showing images of them in their
Bentleys or rolls royces or I mean I
have a nice watch but like you don't see
me show that [__] anywhere I like when
people are showing themselves in their
private planes or whatever I just think
they're missing the whole boat and then
what they're doing is they're
perpetuating the PlayStation situation
they're doing it again and again and
they're doing it because
it doesn't make them happy anymore to
have it that's not enough I have to show
a bunch of people I got it and what they
should actually be showing is
man I just invested in my first stock
that's [__] cool look at my I mean if
you look at my stuff it's like I have
laundromats and car washes behind me all
the time in them because that's the
stuff that you should try to strive for
you can actually pass it down it can pay
you back you can buy as many
PlayStations as you want but I think to
your point the other thing is we are all
you know have you ever felt um like when
you're around other people and uh and
they're sort of negative or they want to
talk about people the whole time and
like how that energy feels it's like
it's draining right even if you kind of
get caught up in it it's fun for a
second at the end you're like [__] how
was it I feel kind of gross for having
that combo I think it's the same with
ads and stuff that we take into us and
so they're basically creating our
stories for us in social media by
showing all this fancy stuff and then we
start to have this memetic desire this
external desire and belief that we
actually that we want it that we need it
but we don't we're just becoming a
replica of the people that we're
surrounding ourselves with which are now
social media there's no even growing up
there's no laundry mats and 50 cents
videos yeah that's what I mean it should
be that's all sports cars and mansions
and stuff so that was my North Star as a
young black man it was like how do I get
a mansion and a sport in a sports car
and in the first page of my diary 18
years old it says four things on which
you perform 25. bear in mind I was
shoplifting pizzas at the time and I was
um a university Dropout not speaking to
my parents with two ccjs which is like
when the court is coming for you for
death I wrote a Range Rover Sport will
be my first car didn't have a driving
license until I was 23.
um I'll make a million pounds I'll work
on my body image again because I'm a
very small kid and I'll get a girlfriend
those are my four goals in life and they
were totally influenced by
the outside world that's why my book is
called happy sexy millionaire because I
thought if I became a sexy millionaire
then I would become everything I needed
to be
and I was so wrong I mean I don't regret
the decisions I made because you can't
really in hindsight but um
I wish I had better influences to say
the least yeah I mean I think that's why
content's so important you know I think
about
I think about Warren Buffett's annual
shareholders meeting right which you can
go and attend if you if you're on Stark
and you don't have to own much of it
um
and I think you know people made fun of
me when I started creating content
online because they were like oh big
successful private Equity person now
you're taking your own money and if you
really had companies that made 80
million dollars in Revenue that means
they're you know you're worth a couple
hundred million bucks uh and if that's
the case why would you be making
Instagrams and tick tocks and that
doesn't make much sense right
and my reaction at the time was I think
we should make it just as entertaining
talking about stuff that makes us money
as we do stuff that costs us money I
think probably that'd be good and if we
could do that that'd be a worthy Mission
and also it'd be fun to try to do it I
don't know if we could do it but um
yeah maybe the next rap videos I mean
and now now for honestly my favorite
deals to break down are the celebrity
deals because they're fascinating like
the rock have you ever looked at the
Rocks content from a uh product
perspective
brilliant so the rock if you look at his
content so let's just talk Instagram if
you go to The Rock's Instagram I want
you to count how many pieces of content
he has that have product placement in
them of companies he owns and the answer
is close to 80 so almost every single
post the rock does is an ad but what do
we really see we see sexy tequila we see
ABS we see him with this beautiful wife
like we see these other things but we
don't realize that every single one of
them is an ad and so what if we could
flip that around like wouldn't it be
cool if the rock talked about the deals
he did too and how he did that now he
goes back and he talks about how he
stole stickers bars similar to you with
with pizza but I think even for
celebrities they don't want to talk
about the deals that they did they just
want to talk about all the money that
they have it almost seems like faux pas
somehow to talk about the deals and how
good a deal making they are like Reese
Witherspoon
billionaire now why because Reese
Witherspoon little sweet Susie sunshine
and pink basically took a book club
and said to authors I'll give you part
of my platform for you to talk about
your book because I'm lovely it's free
you're going to sell a bunch of books
tiny insignificant detail I'd like the
future rights to turn your book into a
movie and I'll pay you some sum or I'll
have a right of first refusal AKA I have
I get the right to buy it before anybody
else and I'll pay you then for it the
author goes amazing Reese of course
perfect they come on Reese basically a b
tests so tests out which books do best
and depending on which books do best uh
Reese bought Reese buys their movie
rights and makes movies that create you
know tens of millions or hundreds of
millions of dollars in Revenue but Reese
doesn't tell that story Reese tells the
Susie Sunshine story of her selling the
books I think the other story is more
interesting and more people can learn
from it
so when I hear these deals and when I
see these big success stories we've got
Kylie we've got the Rihanna's of the
world we've got Ryan Reynolds The Rock
Reese Witherspoon
the question that we must always be
asking ourselves I certainly ask is was
that them
or did they just have a great advisor a
financial advisor that came along at
some point and went by the way you do it
like this yeah and you'll make [__]
shitloads yeah well my question is who
cares I still want to know the secret
sauce yeah and so she's none of them are
that dumb where they don't know what the
deal was right like even if somebody was
smarter than them which could be Reese
may have a genius behind her the rock
too probably Danny Garcia his wife his
manager Kylie yeah the the goat you know
which is weird to say about the
Kardashians but you know behind them the
mom for sure but they're you know
they're smart enough when you create
that much wealth and you do it
continuously multiple times like Reese
has done with Draper James too you
definitely know what's going on so I
think like sharing those Secrets would
be cool but that's usually where people
go people go well they're famous so it's
easy for them or you know who did the
deal and I'm like yeah maybe it's
scooter Brawn behind the scenes but I'd
like I'd like to know how they
structured that the reason they don't
tell you though is because it feels like
it's the opposite of the authenticity
trying to maintain nailed it so if they
came out and went listen the way we did
you on that whiskey deal I got 50 my job
was to post it with the abs every week
and you guys [__] bought it and now
it's worth a billion dollars is the how
to they can't do that deal again because
everything they touch I'm gonna think oh
it's a deal well I think you could do it
in a way that was real like you could be
like we did this business and maybe you
could give some of it away like you
could be like you know if if the rock
makes a billion dollars off of
terramanna couldn't he then say we would
never have done a billion dollar deal
unless you guys bought it because you
bought it we're going to give you some
Equity we're gonna allow people to buy
into Equity at the company at a lower
valuation and have access to it I mean
that's kind of what venture capital and
crowdfunding does right so I mean they
can do whatever they want to do but I
think there's so many ways to get around
it
and maybe there's nothing but downside
because people these days get mad when
people make money and so maybe people
would hate that but God I think it'd
make a lot more humans Rich for people
to be honest about how they got there
you know I reflect as you were speaking
on a conversation I had with a cab
driver in the UK he said to me you know
are you that Diary of a CEO guy I
listened your podcast in the cabs and
you know I'm I'm working three jobs this
is one of them and I'm trying to what he
was saying was I'm trying to find
Financial Freedom yeah I'm working this
cab job I'm doing this other little
thing on the side but I'm trying to find
the way I'm trying to find the way to
get out of this life into and he was
scrambling around he was saying to me
you know my friend does some stuff in
Africa and in Ethiopia and he's got
something there with property so I might
go there and yeah there's this other
thing I might do
those people those are the ones that I'm
trying to speak to today those ones that
are like looking for the way out
well first of all cab drivers and Uber
drivers are my people yeah I always yeah
I always chat with them well and they
always listen to my stuff because they
know small business like they have a
friend that owns a laundromat or they
have a friend that works inside of a car
wash or owns a car wash these are like
blue collar businesses right
um but usually what I would say to them
is something I actually said to one of
the guys that's with me today I'd say
try to break your frame entirely most
people look for individual next tactics
so they're like what can I do over the
next one two or three years to get here
one thing I think is really helpful to
do is say okay you have a three-year
goal
break the frame how could you achieve
that goal in six months what would be
something so different
so out of the box
so big that the goal that was going to
take you three to six years is now going
to take you six months and I want you to
spend some time on that spend a week
spend a weekend deeply thinking about
that idea because what you're going to
do is you're going to come up with ideas
for the person that could be the impetus
for your Financial Freedom or for the
business risk that's super smart but you
haven't been wanting to take it and I
think most people they like they Wade in
the shallows of life and you cannot
have massive change by going shallow and
so
I like to say when people want to an
answer I like to answer ask them a
question because I think they know I
think they know deep down inside but
they get scared just like I did and so
they wait years to do the thing that
they knew they should have done earlier
and I don't think you need a guru or a
podcast to tell you that I think you've
got to break your frame and say I'm
super capable if I was going to do this
crazy thing in six months if anything
was possible if I really believed in
myself what could I do who could I go to
that could make an unfair Advantage for
me and I do think that book who not how
people usually read it as Leaders
because it's a lot about hiring but I
think it's actually about life and I
think usually your answer to Freedom is
a who not a how because often for
Hustlers and people who are going to
work hard you know one or two people who
are very wealthy or who run big
businesses there are a few people in
your ecosystem that you could go to and
become their Hustler for them and that
can lead to Fantastic Financial reward
because most people are not Relentless
in the pursuit of the things that they
want if you can be relentless you can
accomplish way more than the average
person
and most of us you used a phrase earlier
on in this conversation which really
stuck with me because I've used this
phrase with my friends over and over
again you said you got to see behind the
curtain
and I remember
the first moment in my life where I
really felt like I got to see behind a
curtain that I didn't even know was
there for anyone listening to this
podcast there's a curtain on my right
for anyone watching you can see the
curtain on my right behind that curtain
there is actually a room in there and
there's actually another studio in there
where we record some content it's kind
of like a standing up Studio we've got
some backdrops and stuff like that but
the analogy that I'd give you is in life
you never know how many other rooms
there are behind the wall and there was
a point in my life where I started
understanding deals and the public
markets and how
certain High net worth individuals were
playing what I call money games they
were basically not doing much work but
they understood the laws of money so
they could buy things at an Arbitrage or
flip things and Arbitrage and make put
them on the public markets and all of
these crazy money games that no one had
ever told me about in life I thought the
way you build wealth is by working
and these [__]
the richest people I know do very little
working and they do a lot of money games
and they live behind the curtain that I
didn't even know was there
um and I was thinking about the cab
driver there there's so many what is
behind the curtain the behind the
curtain is a bunch of information that's
essentially what it is you know a bunch
of people that have a bunch of
information what I might say to that cab
driver is like who can take you behind
the curtain even if you have to go get a
[__] job for six months yep like you
were alluding to it there like is there
a guy or a woman that I could go just
Shadow just make the [__] tea and get
behind the curtain and figure out how
they do it yep like if you wanted to be
the best podcast in the world or you
wanted to be a good podcaster
if you can go clean the floors 100 you
know what I mean a lot of people don't
want to want to do that they want to
work their way there but uh
so much in life is about information
right and the information you you don't
even know that you don't have oh yeah
when did you see behind the curtain well
you worked in finance so that's unfair
yeah I think I think it is a hack
um I saw behind the curtain for the
first time when I had managers and
bosses who were making tens of millions
of dollars a year and I realized
how little they worked like you said but
also how average they were you know I
saw these
largely
you know middle-aged dudes who
um were no more impressive than I was
and they were crushing it and instead of
having Envy or hate for that I was super
curious am I ah this guy can do it that
means I can do it and I think that's a
huge unlock actually I was talking with
another friend the other week and I
think one of the secrets to success
might be when you see somebody who has
more who is doing better who has more
money
realizing that means that you can get it
as opposed to I hate them because they
have it if you can flip that mindset
on the other side of that lives nothing
but opportunity and and it keeps I keep
finding new rooms in the house new
curtains behind it and I'm not sure that
will ever stop I mean I was talking to
my friend Bill Perkins the other day
who's a hedge fund manager and Bill
um is very successful huge you know
compound house we're walking around at
I'm like this place is pretty nice and
uh and he said to me Cody
um
you know do you think that you because
you've been around small business for so
long small has infected your thinking
and I was like oh God
oh God you know
I don't [__] I don't know and and but
then I realized to him it had because
he's got way more zeros than I do and so
like those zeros become unlocks to the
curtain I mean the other day I was
flying home yesterday or flying here
yesterday and I sat next to Jeffrey Kent
the CEO and founder of Abercrombie in
Kent and he built that business up to
multiple billions of dollars before
selling it he played polo with the king
is quite close with King Charles and
um you know uh also has traveled the
world came from nothing in South Africa
was in a town in South Africa where
there are only 100 white people which is
fascinated
um like mostly was barefoot all
throughout his childhood and created the
luxury travel Market essentially and I
was just sitting next to him on on the
airplane and I kind of looked at his
watch and I was like that's a nice watch
and I sort of looked at his mannerisms
and I was like I just have a feeling
this guy is worth a lot of money and so
I started chatting with him I just said
you know hi like I'm Cody and you know
why were you in town what were you doing
in Khan and
um he lives now in Monaco and what I
thought was so interesting is when I
talked to him I said what do you think
the secret is like you're a billionaire
like what is that how do you become that
and he said there's really one
ingredient to success and that
ingredient is the thing that everybody
has but everybody wastes
time time
he's like I ran my company for 61 years
61 years running one company he goes can
you imagine what the compounding looks
like in 61 years focused on one thing he
goes this generation cannot imagine
and and then we went a little deeper and
I said you know what do you think is the
biggest difference between entrepreneurs
today and entrepreneurs when you were
really in the game because he's in his
80s now
and he said well back then we
we were explorers of the only Frontier
that still existed which was business
you know they were the the privateers
asking money for the king and queen to
buy a ship to go to the to the new land
right except he was doing it in a
business sense he went to China in 76
and was the first person to open up the
Chinese market to travel you know he uh
broke so many bones uh playing Polo that
he had to retire at a young age like
they were hard men and I think about it
with um
with with us today I think that we've
become a generation of vitamin D
deficient uh all birds wearing uh
computer programming alternative milk
drinking softies in many ways and some
of my most successful friends who are
worth so much monetarily their health is
not very strong they don't adventure and
they don't have true difficulty and I
think that's the difference between his
generation and ours and between true
success and not is this idea that I'm
sort of playing with like a third degree
human somebody who has a strong mind a
strong bank account a strong body those
three things all together and where we
don't just take other people's risk
meaning take other people's money to run
our business but we we take the risk
ourselves
and I think his generation really did
many things wrong I don't want to
glorify it but I think they did that
right and how much more interesting is
it to do these big huge things and maybe
if you do that you break the frame
entirely
um
and I every time I meet with a
billionaire my mind just kind of
it expands a little bit more and I think
it's the same way like the first time
you met like my parents weren't
millionaires when I was growing up so
the first time I met a millionaire I
thought whoa like this is a what is this
magic land you know this person has so
much money they don't know what to do
with it and then you meet the first Deca
millionaire and then you meet the first
hundred millionaire and at each level
not that we want to worship money or
that money is all there is but it is a
scoreboard for a game that a lot of
people are playing in this Society
and I think it's interesting to try to
get in those rooms and these days those
rooms are open you know back when we
were first doing our businesses a
billionaire didn't write a book you know
a podcast or do a podcast or tweet or go
shake your hand at a conference that was
unheard of and now they're all around
what have you noticed in billionaires
what's the trend you know people I've
met a quite a lot of billionaires now
and there tends to be some similarities
yeah they all get there in different by
different routes and different paths but
similarities in character and philosophy
yeah
one is I've found most billionaires I've
met have a mission so big it dwarfs the
pain that comes with built-in because I
do think it's more comfortable by and
large it's more it's like the low dull
pain
is being in a job
you know that's like kind of like having
a little ache constantly being in a job
being an owner an entrepreneur or trying
to strive for billionaire status is a
roller coaster ride of extreme pain at
some points or maybe you'd say extreme
pain at some points extreme pleasure and
you kind of go like this right you have
to be able to Wade through that and so I
find that most of them are the opposite
of what I thought they'd be I thought
they'd just be like Scrooge McDuck like
swimming around in their riches they'd
be kind of shallow maybe you know maybe
they'd be super self-interested they'd
only be focused on their own thing they
wouldn't be nice I wouldn't want to meet
them and actually what I find they're
Inc this is going to sound like a gross
generalization but most of them really
want to help you up when they realize
that you're hungry like when they see
the hunger paired with the ability and
willingness to take action they want to
help you it's so rare like if you're
listening and you have that desire but
you actually do the hard things you're
rare you're actually really rare because
everybody says they want it but nobody
really wants to do it I mean I knew I
had to fire one of my employees back in
the day which made me really sad the
second that that person told me that
they had a bunch of debt
uh they were working in the business
with me obviously they had a bunch of
upside in the business but they decided
to take some of their cash and they were
going to invest in a day day trading uh
thing in the stock market and I said I
really don't think you should do that I
think if you want to take that cash and
buy a business we should talk about that
I can help you if you want to focus more
on a secondary business that increases
your income but if you want to day trade
what you're telling me is that you want
to get rich fast and you want to
speculate that you want to get lucky you
don't want to earn it and anyway they
kind of laughed and then they did the
thing and that was in that moment I knew
you don't have what it takes at this
level maybe you could change but if
you're going to make that decision now
you're telling me you're a short-term
player and long-term games with
long-term people like Naval ravacott
said is the goal so that's what
billionaires have they think long term I
was actually just talking with a member
of my team on the taxi on the way over
here and there's a close to a
billionaire that I've become friends
with here and I was like why do you
think he's inviting us to do this stuff
you know who this is and um and I was
like I'm not a big enough name for this
like there are other people you know
what's the Thought here and then what I
think I realized is that
this guy is taking a bet that I might
keep growing my social platform and I
might keep spending on it and in two to
three to five years I might be a really
big name and because he Associates with
me now when he needs something in two to
three to five years I'll be really big
and he'll have like a remember when
moment here and he could go get a Damien
John right and pay to do something with
the Damian John but then he doesn't have
the remember when moment because
Damian's already at the top right and so
that billionaire almost billionaire is
thinking
three to five years out with a potential
call option AKA a maybe possibility
how often do we do that I don't even do
that enough and so that's where I think
they're different it's just this
different scope because probably they
see many curtains
with that long-term view they want to
water some seeds right
I I can totally relate to that I've
often say been perplexed in my life by
way extremely rich people wanted to give
me a hand right especially when I was
like 18 kid with an idea all the
enthusiasm in the world you know but you
know you almost don't trust it right it
was so weird yeah I've described it as
bit being so unusual over and over again
every year for the last 10 years that
when I was 18 19 years old and I stood
on those stages and I went around again
stealing the Chicago time pizzas in my
spare time to feed myself but all of
these really successful people wanted to
give me a hand like wanted to introduce
me to someone you know give invest in my
business even though I had no
credentials they just saw something in
me that I never understood that would be
an interesting thing to try to break
down what is it that you see in another
human I mean one of the things that
comes to mind for me is how many people
reach out to you every single day a DM
you know I'd love to meet you Stephen
could you help me with this could you I
would guess a lot
so probably a lot but what I found is
interesting is in the beginning when I
was starting to be a little public I
would respond to almost all of them
almost every single one I would respond
but I would respond like this I would
say
happy to help read this book and then do
XYZ thing for me something very small
I'm like read this book first do this
small thing do you know how many people
did that oh cool none [__] off that's a
great saying I'm gonna use that [__] all
not a single person actually did that
and then if you compare that with I
think I've hired five team members now
who all reached out to me with value
they gave right away one of them did
this a deep analysis on my business
another one basically wrote up this
whole piece like she was me and it was
incredible and for those individuals who
actually asked nothing of me I gave them
a job and opportunity and many of them
make six figures plus and so there might
be a secret there that just the humans
who do are the ones who follow up the
the DM tells me everything I need to
know about the person yeah and I I can
give you every example of every DM that
I ever get and how I feel to them
how I know from the first DM whether
they are someone that I should be
connecting with let me give you the one
side of the spectrum the one side of the
Spectrum which I often get is
any jobs going
in that you've told me everything I need
to know because not only could you have
checked if we had jobs available correct
on our many websites where we list our
vacancies you didn't even have enough
effort to like go check out the job site
um didn't say hello poorly structured
message
um you think that we hire over DM on the
basis of no pitch at all that's the
extreme example but it happens you
wouldn't believe I will get any jobs
going once a day without fail on one of
my inboxes
and sometimes and I've never said this
before on a very rare occasion I'm
saying once a year I'll click on the
person's profile
and I'll
care about them so much that I'll send
them a voice note so because I look I
click on their profile I remember this
one kid and he kind of look like me oh
yeah and he was a young kid and I
remember thinking I really you know I
could just ignore it it's easy thing to
do the hard thing to do was try and give
them some feedback on like please don't
do that to more people please don't send
them any jobs go in question mark So I
remember sending one particular kid like
a voice note saying right listen buddy
I'm on your side here here's some advice
um and then on the extreme end the good
what happened what happened and the
response was he he was thankful oh
that's good but when he responded I
realized why he was the type of person
that would send any jobs going maybe a
bit of a maturity issue there sure
and then on the other end you have the
perfect reach out where someone realizes
that they can't give you what they're
asking to take from you yeah so someone
wants maybe an hour of your time they
know they can't give you anything worth
an hour they can't give me 50K they
caught nothing nothing they can give me
worth that hour of my time
but they do two three things maybe the
first is they realize that
and so they realized that they should
offer something of value even I'm not
never going to take it they but the
gesture itself it's like someone pulling
out their card to pay the gesture itself
matters it does the third thing is they
realize the world that I live in and
that I have no time and they acknowledge
that so they might say listen you get
thousands of messages like this
um I know how busy you are
so just by them saying that I go okay
you understand yeah um could I could I
just sit so I see it as an equation ask
for as little as possible and give
whatever you can could I just sit in the
room one day when you work means a lot
to me the third point there is research
the person because that's a huge show of
care yeah I know you're a big Manchester
United fan I know your dog's called
Pablo
in exchange I will I don't know [__]
I will I've made this jacket for Pablo
I've sewn it myself if someone said that
to me people are going to do this Pablo
does not need a jacket we're coming into
summer he likes being naked
um but just showing you you made an
effort oh my God it's the keys to my
heart yeah it's true um and then ego is
a great thing as well everyone has an
ego so just acknowledging you've you've
done your research on someone it's
another huge way yeah and I think the
sneak too if you're listening is like
skip the famous people they get enough
yeah like forget it email them like yeah
just skip them all you know even like
sort of famous people like skip all that
and go to people with money because
often they're quiet people can't find
them they don't get a lot of reach out
and so if I was young and hungry I would
skip the flash skip the the Bentleys
skip the Rolexes skip the fame and I
would go straight to like who's the
richest sprinkler owner you know like
who's the guy on your block that has the
biggest house that does something that
sounds so boring to you because you also
learn the most from like the level like
closest to you and if you can kind of
like level up a little bit you know if
you go from you right now to billionaire
and billionaire goes the thing is you
got to work hard kid you're like [__] I
don't know what that means you know but
if if you go to the next person and
you're like no the thing is you have to
send this exact email which is what I
sent to this person they're so much
closer to your climb you know they
remember the steps
um and they want to meant they want
someone to Mentor they do yeah they'd be
most flattered by you know that I have
300 sprinklers around London like they
would be blown away by someone taking
such amount of effort and care to
research them exactly yeah and you know
and they probably had to do really
interesting things to create their
wealth that weren't single events you
know if you reach out to somebody who is
now I know about the show on love Island
like what are they going to teach you
like yeah kid be charismatic kind of hot
and get on a TV show here's application
form yeah exactly yeah
okay and then have a bunch of money and
get famous uh but if you reach out to
somebody who built a toilet business
here like that's there's probably a lot
they had to do continuously over time
that you could learn from but it's not
that sexy so people don't do it
a quick word on heal as you know they're
a sponsor of this podcast and I'm an
investor in the company and I have to
say it's moments like this in my life
where I'm extremely busy and I'm flying
all over the place and I'm recording TV
shows and I'm recording shows in America
and here in the UK that huel is a
necessity in my life I'm someone that
regardless of external circumstances or
professional demands wants to stay
healthy and nutritionally complete and
that's exactly where heel fits in my
life it's enabled me to get all of the
vitamins and minerals and nutrients that
I need in my diet to be aligned with my
health goals while also not dropping the
ball on my professional goals because
it's convenient and because I can get it
online in Tesco in supermarkets all over
the country if you're one of those
people that hasn't yet tried Hill or you
have before but for whatever reason
you're not a real consumer right now I
would highly recommend giving huel a go
and Tesco have now increased their
listings with huel so you can now get
the RTD ready to drink in Tesco
expresses all across the UK
why is it important for you now the last
two years you've started making content
why is it why do you think everybody
should make content what are all the
upsides you've seen in your life some of
the unexpected ones too please that have
resulted from you becoming a content
creator
the most unexpected one
I wanted every single person that I
wanted to reach out to to pick up my
phone call like I don't ever want to be
the person standing in line at the club
I want to own the club I want to get the
invite I'm actually
another good example I was just with my
friends in Khan and they were like let's
try to get into this party or this party
I'm like I was invited to this one I'm
gonna go to this one because I don't
like doing the hustling to try to get
into the I don't like it I've never
liked it it's probably a like I should
get better at it I should get over
myself who cares but I was like I'm not
gonna try to like finagle my way in
that's the short-term game right right
and it feels gross and it feels thirsty
and I want to be thirsty and so creating
content is a way for you to have unfair
access in a world
um you know these days how do I become
friends with billionaires because they
watch my weird content on laundromats
and car washes and they see something in
it and so that if if we truly believe
that money
is power I think the way you get money
is usually people which is like a theme
we've kept coming back to most people on
the internet I think try to explain how
smart they are and what I hope to
express is like I'm not that smart I
just found people you know and I think
we can all do that so that was one I
don't I don't want to be standing in
line in the club trying to like finagle
my way in I want to find that what's the
what's the back door that nobody's
talking about where they invite you into
it that's one you know the second is I
suppose on that yeah because I think
that's it's that's not just a nightclub
analogy that's that is a philosophy
towards every facet of your life being
the magnet or the peacock instead of the
door-to-door sales person yeah like you
know what I mean like all my companies
have grown on this basis all of my
companies have grown on the basis this
is maybe my biggest one of my least
shared business Secrets is that all of
my companies don't have outbound sales
teams because we make content and we
know I know that 99 of my competitors
are gonna go the door-to-door salesman
route they're gonna go Network events
you will in the last 10 years you have
never seen me swanning around a network
event
content is networking yeah I agree you
will never catch me I won't have a
business card I'm not going to hand it
to you I won't even be there on stage
out the back to meet people hello hello
hello out the back door straight back
onto LinkedIn yeah to start making
content people don't realize that and
it's much easier it's a much more
sustainable more cost efficient
long-term strategy if
you know how to do it yeah well I mean
and if you actually want to see me like
sweat it would be having to go Network
Small Talk hit like oh God I want to die
um and I had to do sales for so long in
finance you know Finance is just all
sales we used to at Goldman we had like
a spreadsheet that they would track
every single day how many cold calls you
made when we were trying to sell a deal
and um it was awful you know I remember
one time I was like pretending like I
understood Golf and so I'm like ah it
was great like how was how was the game
yesterday did you did you get the goal
and they were like what the [__] you
talking about you know I don't know
anything about it miserable
um it's like a fishing rod versus a net
isn't it the fishing rod can only catch
one fish yeah it's true if I throw that
[__] net out which is making a
banging video about the subject matter
or the industry I could catch 300 fish
that's exactly right takes the amount of
time yeah I mean it's push first pull
yeah do you want to have do you want to
pull people to you or do you want to
have to push and you know scream and I
just I'm not interested in that so
that's why I think content so so
powerful the other thing about content
is you find your humans I mean it can
get
it can get a little lonely you know
having built a bunch of stuff and had
some success and I've had many times
where over the years
the person that I've become is not the
person that the people I love loved you
know and so I had to I had to move past
that [__] yeah and it's it sounds you
know everybody I I will often tweet
things that are things to myself it's
like notes to me and that happens to be
in a tweet form
and one of them is like you know you get
in a room with people who are smarter
than you and then you leave when that's
no longer the case and that's not saying
that you get rid of friends but
typically they'll get rid of you like
when you're outgrowing people it's
uncomfortable for the people that you've
outgrown they don't like to see that you
are moving forward it's such a fast
progression which I wish it wasn't that
way but you know I had a girlfriend that
I was friends with for [__] you know
now I'm feeling old but like you know
almost 20 years like 18 years and when I
started getting like kind of notoriety
on the internet uh I didn't realize it
bothered her you know but it did and so
you know at one point she's like you're
posting about all your other friends and
not me and I was like oh I only post
business stuff you know I didn't I
didn't my parents aren't on there's no
personal stuff on there I keep that
pretty private so I didn't realize that
was important to you and this was a rift
that just like never healed and so I
think that happens continuously but I
like content because then I find the
humans who
actually want you to win like get super
inspired by that when you find those
people I think it's worth more than the
winnings
amen
amen there is a shedding people didn't
talk about this enough that when you
start putting yourself out there
especially when you start becoming a
quote unquote thought leader yeah the
people that knew you before
look at you and think
who the [__] does he think he is you
think you think you're Gandhi or Martin
Luther King Steve yeah like come back
down here with us right you know that
must have happened to you in a big way
yeah I think
definitely I almost think of my life as
being in school leaving to go to
university dropping out of University
being a being pretty much alone and
having a chance to reinvent myself and
then emerging as who I really was yeah
and um I have no current friends that
from school still well no one that I
speak to for my school days and I have
no one really even from that University
phase everybody has been since because
you know this is what I'm into and so
it's a new person to resonate with or
not resonate with so it's it's I think
that's actually very very true I think
can't like if you had friends that were
super excited for you still at this
point and were curious and growing and
they don't have to be monetarily growing
it could be totally different they could
be obsessed with MMA and all they want
to do is is doo do Jitsu but that's
that's their area of of expertise you
would you would respect that and value
that and you guys could stay friends but
what typically happens is when you grow
a lot it's this it's like holding a
mirror in front of somebody else and
saying all the time why aren't you doing
the things that you can and the things
that you could be capable of and when
people see that mirror non-stop they
start to look at you and think I don't
like what I'm looking at
and so I've I've really had to come to
terms with that too what my path is is
not perfect it's not right I mean
sometimes don't you wish you could just
like actually Netflix and chill like you
didn't want to achieve all the time I
certainly do I'm addicted to achieving I
love it I wish I could slow down
sometimes there's a big difference here
actually because you said you started on
this path at 30. yeah so maybe the
reason I didn't experience it as much as
I started at 18. I hadn't built a career
and I hadn't built social circles around
me when I started to make content and
start these businesses and started you
know talking on the TV about business
and whatever else so I didn't have as
much to shed as much of a built up
identity to shed oh good point but I do
I meet people all the time that are you
know 40 50 that are thinking about
making an identity pivot that are like
trapped by the identity and Social
Circle they've built yeah and the
expectations that comes with that it's a
good point yeah it's harder the bigger
the walls you've built in terms of
identity and the more established your
identity is I think that's a really good
point yeah I mean I think I had to get
divorced quit a job move a city
uh and change a lot of things that
weren't who I felt like I was
are you happy you know way happier now
yeah but you know it's a miserable thing
leaving another human behind you know
like
um you know I don't I don't wish divorce
on anybody I don't like whenever I meet
somebody who's divorced I always say I'm
sorry and congratulations because it's
kind of both
um was your decision it was my decision
yeah we just wanted different lives you
know he he was very happy in a white
picket fence Country Club
life and uh wanted a couple kids and
wanted to stay really locally based and
kind of wanted me to not work
and so when I thought about my life I
was like I want to live all around the
world and I want to build something so
big that I can't sleep because I need to
create it and and I want to leave a
legacy that is not
um managing director at a private Equity
Firm and I'm not ready for kids and and
I'm not sure I want to have kids with
you
and he really wanted me to change and
I'm not sure that we should ever try to
change somebody that we're with there's
going to be thousands of people that
have heard you say what you just said
and think [__] that's me yeah I'm in
that job with that partner in that City
and I just know I'm unhappy I can just
feel it there's this like sense of
you know there's a signal inside me
telling me that I shouldn't be here and
I can I can hear it sometimes I I
justify it away or I try and drown it
out but I know
what would you whisper to that person
what did you what would have been words
helpful words to
this Kodi at 36 to whisper to that Cody
at 29.
two words my dad said to me which is
exit tax so uh when I left it was
expensive uh and both physically and and
emotionally and uh and I told my dad
about it and he said there's always an
exit tax to Freedom
um and that stuck with me because I was
like oh this is just this is just a toll
it's just a payment but once it gets
paid what's on the other side that word
freedom and one thing that really helped
me actually when I was going through
this which all this is funny because I
don't ever talk about this stuff but um
but I got a little place like I had like
the big house all the stuff whatever
before and I got this little tiny
townhouse
right afterwards actually at one point
like I couldn't get into my bank
accounts and stuff and so I didn't have
much but I got this tiny little
townhouse that I rented and that uh tiny
townhouse nesting in a place that was
just my own that felt really safe was
one of the weirdest unlocks that I've
ever had I now think about it as the
power of place if you can just have
somewhere else that you go to that is
just yours that's my biggest
recommendation for people that go
through let's say a divorce or a really
tumultuous you know change in partner is
there's something about like a glass of
you know I would have like a little
glass of wine or a cup of tea in this
tiny little townhouse but it was mine it
was like nobody else's I didn't have to
share it I didn't have to compromise I
could just be me and from there I could
sort of recreate again
um and I've heard of that now from many
many many women at least who have been
divorced that like that next little tiny
place is really important and I and I
think if I could do it again I'd go back
and buy that place and I'd like maybe
I'll buy a few and I'd give it to women
like more men right after they get out
of their thing because it's almost like
you need to stand on your own Feet Again
you forget how to
so I would just remember there's an exit
tax to Freedom and then on the other
side
don't you know I like to say like
you know I don't think you shouldn't
strive for divorce you know I think
marriage is tough and relationships are
tough and there's a huge benefit to
working through things with one human
for life I take that very seriously but
if you are in fact in something that is
unhealthy and that you should not be in
realizing that the other side
is so much better than I ever could have
imagined I mean I would not have the
life that I live right now which is a
pretty [__] great life if I had
stayed on the side of easy and now you
know when I told my mom she like cried
for days and you know questioned it and
you know was like how are you going to
do this and now
uh she's the opposite she's like you
know yeah it was such the right decision
I'm so happy for you and will say things
to me like you were so brave which is
weird for me to say out loud but that
you did that because most people would
stay
um so that's what I would say there's
definitely freedom on the other side do
you set goals yeah definitely
how do you set your goals and what goals
do you have
well one of the ways that I figured out
uh how to get divorced was actually I
set a date on my calendar so I was like
I'm going to commit to fixing this and
therapy and all of this stuff but if and
here's what we're going to do and here's
the plan and if we can't fix it and this
is like my drop dead date because I was
such a wuss I couldn't do it unless I
put on the calendar
um so I'm a big calendar person I I
really like having a deadline when I
started writing this book my due dates
in like four weeks or something like
that and it's not like I look at it
frequently but it's just out there yeah
it's just this it's this thing that gets
put into your psyche and somehow you can
work backwards so much easier from a
date so it sounds so silly but most
humans will say well in one year or
three years or five years I'm like put
it on your calendar like whatever that
actual timeline is and then try to work
backwards and then for most goals
I believe in short-term goals a hundred
percent maybe daily weekly monthly
annually but three or five year goals
who knows I mean you wouldn't have
thought you were doing this two years
ago I wouldn't have thought so either so
like I might have a really big vision
for 10 years or 20 years but as I get
closer I might realize oh God actually
nope that's not what I want so allowing
yourself that freedom
to not want to be the hot sexy Rich
millionaire with Bentleys and instead
say oh no what I actually want to do is
I want to talk about what I want to talk
about with whom I want to talk about
owning companies I want to and having no
master that's what Rich looks like for
me and if you had stuck with your
original goals that wouldn't have been
the case you got team members employees
yeah some of them are here let's say bro
and does it not feel like it's a bit of
a contradictory message in some ways
where you're trying to get them to stay
but part of their job is to get produce
content with you to get other people to
leave their jobs yeah so I have a really
important differentiator between equity
and ownership in a business and skin in
the game I do not think everybody wants
to be a founder of a business I don't
think everybody wants to be an outright
owner of a business I think everybody
should have ownership always
and so the way that looks in our
business is basically every single
person who works for me even all the way
down to my admin gets skin in the game
so that means that if they do X and Y
and Z they see how they can make more
money directly if they come on to my
team they can all Source us deals and
get a percentage of the carry which
means equity in the underlying companies
I know you know that but for anybody
listening
um everybody on my teams always has had
that and then you know the the other
members of my team and businesses before
like my last uh number two I then left
the business to her she became the CEO
of the business so she has ownership of
the business I don't like I should be
really careful about the fact that if
anybody on my team and they already know
this we just sent a message yesterday
somebody asked for like a testimonial
from me
about work that they had done but their
work wasn't very good so I wasn't going
to give them a testimonial and I said to
the team
any one of our high performers
if you ever want to leave this company
and you're great at this company one of
course I'll open every door for you and
I'll write any testimonial or whatever
you need and in fact if you want to
start your own business I hope I'm the
first phone call because I would like to
invest in you I want to be that guy that
saw that in you
no doubt every single time but that's
not for every human Some Humans want to
be in a business like my number two my
CMO
Chris he doesn't want to run a business
himself but he does want ownership so he
has skin in the game from both a revenue
perspective and from a followership
perspective same with my head of content
same with Christian and our AdSense and
our YouTube channel so I think it's
really important that you make sure when
you continue to work harder you make
more no matter what
so many people have philosophies towards
money you know people will say oh you've
got to save more than you spend you've
got to [__] not have the Starbucks
Coffee that's how you'll get rich what
is your overarching philosophy to
Building Wealth and money do you have
something like a philosophy a mantra
well uh first I think you should have
the [__] coffee I think that is
terrible advice
um so I I like Dave Ramsey I get where
he's going with it but um I think you
cannot save your way to wealth you can
only earn your way to wealth but my
Mantra overall is that I think every
human on the planet should understand
the language of money which is finance
and if you understand the language then
you can speak it fluently and when you
can speak it fluently you can become an
expert in an expertise leads to a bunch
of cash and so everything we do is to
try to normalize deal making or the
language of Finance where like the
Duolingo to Finance on the internet
um and I think
I mean we have a goal if we want to
create a hundred thousand small business
owners and one million financially free
people and we track how many people tell
us they bought a business and how much
revenue and profit they earned
and so my goal is before we're done with
this however long that's going to be I
want to hit those two goals and I think
we'll hit them in the next five years
maybe seven
um but that's that is that is the gold
star for me that and my new mantra which
you might appreciate which is my 2023
Mantra is like no more B players oh my
God
stats where it shows about sitting next
to be play oh it's so good my friend
Vanessa van Edwards showed this to me so
there's this study
done across
hundreds of individuals might be
hundreds of companies it's a big study
um and essentially it shows if you sit
next to an a high performer yeah so if
you have your team sit next to a high
performer you do you will outperform by
15 so a high performer just in your
proximity will increase your performance
by 15 if you sit next to a low performer
or underperformer it will decrease your
productivity by 30 percent
so every B player you bring on board is
not just decreasing their productivity
by 30 it is that energy transfer which
is that everybody around them becomes a
little bit less productive and I think
one of the reasons people want to be
owners of companies is because they feel
that people want to stay at companies
where there's a bunch of winners that's
why I liked Goldman I was like these
guys are so smart I'm learning so much I
want to keep going when I was at
Vanguard I was like oh my God these
schleps are just schlepping around the
office not doing anything I'm not
learning anything and they're by you
know design sort of pulling you back and
down and so I I keep that number on a
notepad next to my computer for me to
one not be the underperformer and two
it's not just about getting rid of
underperformers for you as a CEO it's
not good to do to your team so you know
we've definitely have have had them in
varying companies of mine but we push
relentlessly to either make people
better or help them find the thing that
they can be an a performer at do you
know who's very sticky in companies yeah
B players oh God I know so your players
will get fired big players will hang
around that's exactly right and a
players will probably leave yeah and
well a players will leave if you keep
BNC players they're gone that's true
they're not interested B players will
hang and they will think that you owe
them more is what I found yes they are
the ones that ask for the most they're
the most entitled and they're the most
dangerous in a company it's like a
cancer that you need to to cut before it
spreads which sounds like okay really
um but it's actually true because your
employees are choosing to spend their
life and their time with you and so
every B player that you associate next
to them is actually decreasing their
time and that's not a fair thing to do
or to somebody in the company
it doesn't make firing people easier
it's never easy it's never easy
but it's important yeah
what's the most important thing you
think we haven't talked about
you know we talked to the start of this
conversation about who's listening and
you gave me the three personas and you
we talked about that person that's maybe
in that job and they're trying to find
their way out what is the most important
thing for that person that we haven't
made
maybe just one of my team members was
saying this on the way over they're big
fans of yours they're listening all your
stuff and
um are they a players and looking for
jobs yeah yeah actually one of them
lives here and uh and there's a um is
freelance so he could work for you if
you've touched my other one after it's
gonna be over which one's the a player
they're both they're both a players okay
um yeah we're pretty good I definitely
wouldn't travel around with three
players no chance
um so the um and he said something that
I thought was really good which was
um he was listening to your podcast and
he liked one in particular where you
talked about
um
like all the the failings of people who
are successful and so the only thing
that we haven't talked about is the fact
that
you know we say all this stuff like
don't keep players around get rid of
them you know do this get better and and
and on the flip side of that like there
are many mornings where I'm up at eight
or nine and not five in the morning and
there are many mornings where um I'm
stuck in a tick tock you know Instagram
k-hole and I'm not doing the thing that
I'm supposed to be doing and I think
normalizing the fact that people who
have achieved things also are awful [__]
up don't do the right thing every single
day is important to me because sometimes
I get on these and I'm like I don't want
people to perceive that I'm on some high
horse that's incredibly capable and
productive that's not always the case at
all I have many periods where I have not
done the right thing where I've messed
up on business deals where uh I am
the worst in the room and and I think
that's okay it's natural we're human
we're going to mess up so just making
sure people know that listening you
don't have to be perfect to do any of
this and in fact I'm sure you would
agree we're both so flawed that if I can
figure this stuff out I think any
working John can figure this stuff out
too I'm no smarter than anybody else I
went to a party school I didn't go to
Harvard you know I probably did more
beerbongs than I did you know honors
classes in college and and I still
figured it out and it took me until I
was you know 29 or 30 but that's still
pretty young
um so we have a closing tradition on
this podcast where the last guest leaves
a question for the next guest
I love this question they said
when was the moment you were most afraid
if they don't want to answer it
who's your favorite member of One
Direction
that's great but you don't tell them who
the person was I'm fine
um one I couldn't even name that so I'm
gonna have to answer the question when
was I most afraid actually
um it's so funny they are a comedian I'm
gonna give it away oh okay so when was I
last most afraid
um or when was I most afraid ever this
is sort of silly but um
I hiked a mountain called Mike Mount
Baker and uh it is a technical climb so
you use ice axes and crampons and it's
freezing and I didn't really know what I
was getting into and I don't like the
cold and I don't like heights and I
don't like camping and so three days
hiking a glacial Mountain that's very
high it was like probably not my best
idea but I but I did it and
um
I hated it like for three days I was
with all these other women and they kind
of like liked it and I to be fair I like
kind of thought I was tougher than them
you know and they know this so they can
hear it but you know a lot of them I
have this big career I I come off as
tough I can you know get out there go do
it and then here I was on this mountain
I'm [__] miserable I'm scared of the
heights that I'm gonna fall off and
Tumble to my death I'm freezing I have
to sleep on top of a glacier I can't
sleep you're carrying your your feces in
a bag for three days which is another
fun little side note and we get up on
the second day
it's so vertical that you have to be
roped in to each other on the climb
and I'm at the end of it too which is
awful so I I'll let you know I'm the one
that sees behind us the guides in front
there's like six of us or four of us on
a rope or something like that and we get
up after climbing for two days I'm so
miserable and mad that I said yes to
this and we're on this crater because
there's a volcanic crater before we
climb up what's called the wall which is
an ice wall before you get to the top
where you have to step like like this
with your ice ax to get up the wall and
I like I'm like I almost want to cry I
can't think of anything I want to do
less than this
and everybody's preparing to go up and
um
and I'm just like
I don't think I'm gonna I'm not gonna go
up anymore
and I had all these ideas in my head
like but if you don't Summit like then
you're not tough and you gotta get up
there because these other women are
going to do it and then you're gonna
feel bad and whatever and as I sat there
I was just like what am I trying to
prove like I'm pretty happy Life's good
like I don't have on my bucket list that
I want to Summit Mount Baker I just kind
of said yes to this trip
and it wasn't even the heights that was
so scary or the cold it was like am I
like a failure by not doing this tough
thing that everybody else is going to do
am I going to be the one person that
says like I'm out I'm going down I'm
tapping out I'm done and I like have
this whole dialogue with myself
and then I told the guide and there were
a few of them I was like yeah the thing
is I'm gonna go back down I'm going to
chill at like base camp I'm not going to
sum it and my girlfriends came over and
they were like let's talk about this
let's get motivational and I'm like no
totally fine I just realized up here
that most of my life I've been trying to
like please a bunch of people to goals I
don't care about with things I don't
really want in order to achieve some
ridiculous thing and like I don't want
to climb up there I'm gonna be pissed if
I fall and break my neck doing this
thing I don't even want to do and so I
tell the guide he's like cool I've never
run faster down the side of a mountain I
get down to the bottom I'm happy as a
[__] clam at that point I realize I
have altitude sickness so I'm like
tripping balls in the tent which is
really good that I realized that because
then when I was climbing the wall I
might have gotten dizzy and that
wouldn't have been good and I didn't
realize when you got altitude sickness
you it's it's hallucinogenic so the
tent's like moving as I'm laying in it
but I'm great because I'm back in the
tent on the the like uh second Peak area
and then on the way down
like two of the women blew out their
knees it was like a six hour Evolution
and I just remember thinking [__] like
what if I had done that thing I was so
scared of just because everybody else
told me that I should have done it and I
felt like it took more courage for me to
not do the thing than do the thing so
many people are right now climbing a
mountain where they don't even care
about seeing the view
you know I hate why do we do that
so yeah I think sometimes you know they
say everything you want is on the other
side of fear and it's like
if
the thing that you want is the thing on
the other side of fear it's not every
fear we have to charge into and so
I guess choose your Mountain wisely
right
amen thank you Cody thank you for your
time your wisdom and your entertaining
captivating storytelling and uh
and insights it's really really valuable
to our audience there's not many people
like you out there so it's so wonderful
to get to speak to someone and the
mission that you're on is such an
important one I love it for so many
reasons I love it because you you
glamorize the unglamorous and I often
think in so many facets of our life the
easiest way is in fact the boring way
yeah it's the the way that isn't going
to get the likes and the Applause on
Instagram and there's not there's not a
market for that right there's a market
for the quick shiny it's
six pack abs in three minutes all that
stuff there's the market for that or the
nfts the cryptos the get rich quick
schemes you present the important
counter narrative and you do it as an
incredibly powerful honest willing to be
vulnerable woman in business and we need
more of that because
business and the the crater world of the
entrepreneurship Community is heavily
dominated by men right now and that is
that is not a bridge that um
many people can relate to those stories
and where they've come from and the
battles that they face so you present
the counter narrative and it's a very
important one so I also bet on you like
our mutual friend does in a big way and
I can't wait to see a revolution as you
climb that worthy Mountain over the next
couple of years well thank you for
having me this was a pleasure totally
different podcasts I can see why so many
people listen to you so thank you for
having me today you're very kind thank
you Cody
ladies and gentlemen as you know Zoe is
now sponsoring this podcast and I'm a
proud investor in the company and I've
been going on the Zoe Journey myself it
all starts with this home testing kit
you get sent in the post which measures
your gut health your blood sugar and
your blood fat I've had this little
device this blood sugar glucose sensor
on my arm which came in the home testing
kit to understand how all of the
different foods that I eat day to day
have an impact on my body and it's been
pretty unbelievable a big thing for me
is feeling tired after I've eaten
something and not understanding why
historically I didn't understand now I
do understand I'd been eating I think it
was like a rice stir-fry with a bit of
chicken and some chili sauce in there
and I saw on my blood glucose chart on
my phone which is connected to the
device that Zoe sent me this huge Spike
and then later in the day I saw a huge
dip when I started feeling that sort of
post lunge slump and what will happen
next is Tim tells me they'll take all of
that data and give me my own
personalized Zoe scores for any food so
I can figure out what I should be eating
and what I should avoid if I want to
avoid those afternoon slumps and if you
want to get started on your Zoe Journey
with me use the code we've got exclusive
code here CEO 10 for 10 off and let me
know how you get on when it arrives
[Music]
oh
you got to the end of this podcast
whenever someone gets to the end of this
podcast I feel like I owe them a greater
debt of gratitude because that means you
listen to the whole thing and hopefully
that suggests that you enjoyed it if you
are at the end and you enjoyed this
podcast could you do me a little bit of
a favor and hit that subscribe button
that's one of the clearest indicators we
have that this episode was a good
episode and we look at that on all of
the episodes to see which episodes
generated the most subscribers
thank you so much and I'll see you again
next time